[Music]
who here has never heard of survival
analysis okay cool cool and who doesn't
know what a conversion rate is perfect
so if you raise your hand for any of
those two questions that this talk is
perfectly for you we're gonna go to the
basics and if there's only one thing you
remember from this talk is that
conversion is a function of time and
this is how we should start treating it
instead of it just a snapshot there's a
question so you have time to be - my
night before working at Shopify I work
for a mobile games company we had about
six teams each working on their own game
and when the new game was ready for
release we would start first by doing a
soft launch you go nowhere there's
nothing on important online so the soft
launch is the release it on a single
country where we measure the performance
of the game and we evaluate it against
our benchmarks we looked at things like
me tension average revenue per active
user and conversion rate the next one is
important so I'll win it if you lower
you can book there so when I talk about
conversion rate this is what I mean I
think this is the common thing people
refer to as a simple ratio so you say
conversion rate should be conversion
ratio it's a way to estimate the
proportion of your users that will spend
why that is important is because it's a
free-to-play game so we make zero
dollars from people just trying it we
need people to spend in the game one day
we had released a new game and a week
later I was making
report evaluating what what levers we
should change in the games and what we
should improve and I sent the report to
the team and the game had a conversion
rate of five point eight percent after
one week so that was eight hundred pain
users over fourteen thousand users you
don't have to do the math it's there and
I sent it to the team in the management
and the lead designer of the game came
to me shortly after and you really
wasn't happy with my report he's a
Norwegian guy with a big beard and rings
on his fingers imagine like the typical
heavy metal fan and he said and my
Norwegian accent is terrible so I won't
even try to to do one but he said that
my calculation implied to this game he
said that all these players were new so
it didn't work it got me thinking and I
realized that - that he was probably
right - red flags came to my head so
firstly I could not remember a single
game that at soft-launched had a
conversion rate that was comparable to
our benchmarking and second thing was
that conversion rate was that one thing
that we always manage to improve really
early we do an update we had a promo
there and then we move it from 6% to 10%
so it was something that was not hard to
increase it was super fast so what was
happening well it turns out that people
are not as impulsive as we think they
don't jump on the Buy button as soon as
they see one they need to get
comfortable with the product before
spending and if we wanted to represent
that on a graph what would it look like
it would look like something like this
so this is a this secret curve
describing Canute's game and how to
interpret this graph that's pretty
simple this is the number of days since
a group of users have installed a game
and this is the proportion that I've
spent if we apply this curve to my
14,000 new users from
game this is what it would look like
first I'll break down my users because I
want to use my curve and my curves gives
me one information from one conversion
for each day so I break down my users in
two days each cohort is a group of users
that have installed the game on the same
date so the top one 8,000 people that's
the most recent cohort that had the game
for one day the second cohort they have
had this game for two days now I'm using
my curve and I'm gonna grab the
percentages associated with each age
we'll call it the age of the cohort and
if we just do a simple multiplication we
can see the we can see the breakdown of
the pain users includes game and it's
pretty obvious from this point here that
the 5.8 percent conversion rate that I
calculated the snapshot conversion rate
the common method of doing it was
actually very far from the actual
potential of the game because fresh
users dilute the conversion and this is
especially a problem if your if your
company is on the exponential growth
curve where you haven't bought the new
people coming in where most of your
where most of your user base is very
recent it's very difficult to evaluate
the conversion just by taking a snapshot
of your database and doing the death
symbol at the simple calculation I did
early so Kurt was right I can't just do
the simple division but I still want to
compare my games as selfless right I'm
working at a company I want to get tape
so how do I do that well if I have the
curve of every game it would be pretty
easy to put them both on a chart and
look at which one has the highest
conversion over time so in this case if
I had Canute's game against my benchmark
game I can see that after six days enos
game is at 17% conversion while my
top-performing game in my portfolio is
more 25% so when we plot them both like
this they are on an equal footing it's
easy to see which one performs better
given the same time
so how do I get this curve the secret
curve very lucky for us there is already
a Python library that does all the work
it's lifelines it was made by Cameron
Davidson Peale I'm working at Shopify
and for getting this curve we're gonna
use the captain Mayer fitter the name
comes from sorry these two guys I can
get a good picture of Edward captain I'm
really sorry so their method was a way
to estimate survival time when we run
this code that I just showed you you're
gonna get the curve right here which is
not the shape that I've been showing so
far and that's because they worked at
evaluating how long until someone died
in a medical setting so for them the
start of the the start event was someone
was diagnosed let's say with cancer if
you read on survival analysis a lot of
things are treatment for cancer and you
compare two curves you want to know the
proportion of people are still alive
after X number of years given that
they've had treatment a or just a
control group so that's why for them
it's more important to show the people
are that did not have the end event so
start event is being diagnosed and the
van is dying for us the end event is
making your first purchase and we're
really interested in those people so
we're gonna flip this we're gonna flip
this curve on it said very easy we take
the complement of the survival and we
get the curve that we're interested in I
just want to precise a few things about
the data there you'll need because he I
went fast I'm using here I pandas
dataframe are called users and we're
using two columns because we need two
pieces of information about about each
users in your database
we need a column that has converted it's
a very simple boolean that says true if
we have observed that person making a
purchase they've bought that virtual
or the crystal the gems or the sword or
whatever and false if that person has
not yet made a purchase for a duration
it's how long it took that person to
make their purchase so if someone buys
on the second day you you put two days
here and if you've never seen that
person buy you just put the duration for
how long this account has existed for
and after running your code for each of
your user base you're gonna get the two
curves that you want and you're gonna be
able to draw conclusions from that so in
the case where the this obviously is a
fake example where everything is perfect
and the conclusion is really obvious
it's not always the case
in a business setting you probably don't
care if the two curves are closed
because you just want you just want to
ballpark estimate to say if you should
work on conversion or not but if you
want to be more accurate there are
statistical tests that will tell you
when curves are closed if one is
actually different from the other I'm
recovering this here but if you're
interested you can read on that and
that's a pretty simple method oh yeah
question
oh so you could you mean you just take
your cohorts and you blood them yes so
the advantage of using survival is over
this one this is this would work it's
obviously already better than just doing
the common method but here the advantage
is you using all the information for
everyone so instead of saying someone
I'll go back here I have someone here
that okay let's written this guy here
made a purchase on the second day so
instead of just giving us information
about day two of a player's life we're
also getting information about day one
the way to survive what the catenary
method will work is will conclude that
this person also did not convert on day
one so they will lower the ratio on day
one so that way we just Kate take more
information from everyone so your
confidence there will be much narrower
so if you have depending on the size of
your cohorts if you have a lot of people
installing a game every
you can probably proceed like that but
if you wanted something more accurate
then you're used to by Wallaces that way
everyone is taking to account for their
whole lifetime yes well that's a good
question yeah that the problem will be
how do you because this is like as soon
as they make their purchase so you want
to include that type of purchase that
they may like the amount and that's a
very good point
although I'll cover a bit later about
when you want to distinguish between
different conversions so I think you
could you could do that when we have the
next method because here it's a bit
naive in that it conversions the
conversion we don't exactly know what
kind of conversion it is so the method
is very simple but there's a if you read
on it and I'm sure you like I'm not
gonna convert all that all the details
intricacies of it because you can read a
lot of it about it online and most of
the time you're gonna read about it from
the medical point of view and if when
you do that there are aspects that they
don't cover or things that they do that
we cannot do and there are those so two
mistakes that I want to show you that
you should avoid if you use that method
at work
the first one is rounding duration so
don't do what I did in my first example
it was just simplified for the sake of
the example but and my in the first case
I just showed you days and it was always
integers so you might be tempted to do
something like this where you're gonna
use your database and you're gonna query
for each user how many full days have
elapsed since they created their account
or install your app or signed up for
your service and when you do that so if
the person had one point six a day and
six hours it would just give you one for
one day and you're losing something when
you do that so imagine here that it's
written conversions but imagine it's a
race so I have three people on a race
and I'm interested to know what area and
my race are dangerous where people can
trip and fall there is a stick at the
1.7 kilometer and I'm looking there and
I see one people one person jumps and
continues and another one chips in fall
there and my third runner is super slow
he's not there yet so I don't know if
this person is gonna fall at the 1.7
kilometer on my wooden stick
based on what I have right now I can
conclude that 50% of the people chip and
fall on my stick so that third user has
half like 50% chance of falling there
and that's the reality that's perfect
but when you round down so that's what
it would look like I mean the conversion
or the danger the hazard of your the
hazard of your race 50% chance of
falling at the 1.7 kilometer mark and
then when you round your durations down
you lose that ordering and then you you
would conclude that there's a 33% chance
of falling on the one kilometer mark
which is pretty different the red is the
estimate you get when you round down
your durations and the green is the
actual chances of falling there so it's
very common in the medical setting that
they round down two full days because
for them it's unlikely that someone dies
from cancer like two cars two people
died from cancer on the same day so it
doesn't matter but for us it's super
important to keep the order of the event
because when someone converts they are
no longer at risk or susceptible of
converting after so they should not they
should not affect the odds later and so
when you do your query maybe you don't
have data to the micros I can go as
precise as you can if you have
microsecond that's perfect and the
second mistake and it links to the
question I had is using captain Meir
when you have multiple events multiple
ways to end this so so far we only
looked at you bought something you paid
and that's what we care that's all we
care about to explain this mistake I'll
give you a
an example from Shopify so Shopify is an
e-commerce platform where people sign up
to create an online store sell product
charge like credit card payments and
then run their business so when they
come to us we give them 14 days where
they can do absolutely everything for
free and at the end of the 14 days they
get an email saying you need to pick a
plan if you want to continue running
your business online it's all we have
three plans they can choose from each
with a different monthly cost and when
you're running that when you're working
at Shopify you might be interested in
knowing when you do marketing so that
say on Facebook versus some some other
website you want to quantify how much
money you're making from each person you
get from that ad campaign so I had that
question as to me and they wanted to the
not only the conversion global will
converge per plan because someone that
converts that $300 is worth ten times
more than than the basic plan in the way
I approached it was to use Kaplan mayor
the first method that we saw because in
the medical literature very often you'll
see that they say survive on us this is
good when there is censoring and what
they mean by censoring is you don't
actually know when that person is going
to die
so you just conclude at the end of your
study whatever for however long you
follow that person for is all the
information that you have and then you
end it there for us it was what a false
and they also include people lost to
follow up they mean because they were
gonna follow people for very long time
many years and some people move to
another city they don't show up back to
the hospital for a health check so we
don't know what happens to them and so
it's very common in in that setting to
just ignore any anyone that leaves the
study for whatever reason to just
consider them as not dead and stop their
duration so this is what I did I had
data that look like this so I had three
users and they picked different plans
and since captain Mayer is only taking
binary
while binary I mean only a single
outcome is converted or not I decided to
proceed one plan at a time so I would
ignore the person P the people taking
another plan and consider them censored
and this is I'm putting wrong just in
case someone just woke up and decided to
look at the size and was gonna do that
at work like don't do this so I just
replaced it like the actual plan they
took by true or false whether or not I
was the event of interest for me so I'm
drawing a curve at a time one planner at
a time same thing for the second plan
I'm considering the one there that
converted as not converted and I fin it
i ended his duration and then i plot the
results and i'm all happy and I'm about
to show this to the marketing department
then I stop and look at it again and it
doesn't make sense because if you add up
the curve I have more than one hundred
percent conversion rate which makes no
sense obviously so but I was all excited
because you know when you get some
insights you're like well notice how the
$300 plan converts more on the long term
it's something that we could probably
think about about when we reach out to
people later and all that so I went back
to the drawing board and there's
actually another method that you can use
when you want to work for that type of
problem that IO problem in the medical
setting is called competing risks that
means when you do something you have no
chances of doing the other event if you
take the $29 plan
there's no chances you'll take the $79
plan I mean you could but not as your
first conversion event when I use Kaplan
mayor and I sensor things its supposes
that that person could eventually
Kennedy could eventually convert at some
point later like we still in the race
when in reality that person already took
a planet will never never take the $79
plan so how do you handle multiple end
events well you use cumulative incidence
so we're leaving lifelines here and
we're using stats models I'm not a big
kind of stats mom
so most of the things I suggest you do
for survival analysis sessions is to use
lifelines
because it has a lot of other utt
functions but we don't have the
cumulative incidence in Lifeline so
cumulative incidence is nice because
it's going to take into account people
that have already ended for whatever
reason before instead of just censoring
people we can actually tag each user
with the end event that they got so
we're not giving it a converted true or
false but instead we're giving it a code
for some event that interests us and we
leave the 0 for no event yet so in this
situation you can use the code for each
plan if you if you have a case where
you're interested in people upselling
once they're subscribed and they can
also cancel their cancel their
subscription that's another case that
you want to code there because there if
they cancel they can never take the
upgrade and then we get something that's
much more reasonable when we compare
them side-by-side we see that not only
was Savin mer overestimating the chances
of conversion but the ordering also of
the plans is different do the one on
that something so to recap we've seen
that conversion is something that
becomes more likely over time that
survival analysis can help you get an
estimate how much how much it is at each
time point we thought to not round down
durations you want to keep the order of
the conversions to use kaplan-meier only
for a single and event and to use
cumulative incidence when you have
multiple ways to end your life or
confirm convert that's it
[Applause]